welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and Ant-Man Lewis quantumania's Trailer
revealed that Scott will be working with
the nefarious killer king the Conqueror
in a bargain to get more time whatever
that means but during the course of this
adventure he will come across this weird
glowing energy source surrounded by
rings with strange markings on them just
what is this weird yellow Quantum realm
energy source that Scott is trying to
reach with his Jenga Tower of Ant-Man
and how could it be related to the 10
rings from shangchi and one of the most
powerful Marvel Comics heroes of all
time Captain the universe alright gang
so to recap the Ant-Man trailer has
Scott forming an Eiffel Tower of Ant-Man
to reach this yellow source of extremely
powerful energy but what is this weird
glowy yellow [ __ ] huh well judging from
what we know of Janet van dyne's time in
the quantum realm in Ant-Man and the
WASP Janet's body absorbed large amounts
of that strange magical yellow radiation
that allowed her to both heal her
husband's mind as well as temporarily
heal Ava star AKA ghost of her molecular
disequilibrium sickness that gave her a
weird phasey ghost Powers every so
in my body is torn apart and stitched
back together
over and over every day this energy has
been referred to as Quantum healing
particles in the Ant-Man 2 post credit
scene but it's been more primarily known
as Quantum energy which basically just
means energy from the super tiny Quantum
realm automatically start absorbing
Quantum healing particles this is what I
believe the strange Quantum realm
machine is for generating Quantum energy
and the reason I think this is because
the rings that surround the yellow
energy in this trailer are covered in
markings similar to those found on an
early logo for the movie that had the
word quantumania written in this strange
font implying to me that this could very
well be the language used by the people
of the quantum realm itself so this
machine that Ant-Man is pointing his ant
Blaster at and this movie seems to be
one made within the quantum Realm by the
quantum realm people however spinning
ring machines that generate yellow
energy is no stranger in the MCU because
much like I hinted at in my breakdown of
the new Quantum realm trailer the
machine from the Ant-Man trailer is
extremely similar to the yellow golden
energy generators on avguard that
rejected a massive protective Dome of
light around the castle in Thor the Dark
World as well as the anulax battery
power generators the Guardians were
protecting at the beginning of guardians
2. but we of course could not forget
about the time shung Chi used his 10
rings to charge up a massive bottle of
energy like freaking Goku from Dragon
Ball Z like his Rings spun around to
focus and generate energy in this way
too and I do not think that these are
all a coincidence I think that spinning
rings around energy in the MCU indicate
that power is being absorbed and
concentrated into a single spot for a
particular purpose and since we are
dealing with a Quantum realm power
generator here then we're likely dealing
with a concentration of a super
important yet oftentimes forgettable
concept called the Enigma Force Enigma
Force energy a source of energy that is
strongly connected to the quantum realm
in the comics as well as the necrosword
but from 411 Thunder believe it or not
because in the comics the moment the
evil God of Darkness named no got woken
up by the noise and light of the big
bang a god of light was born to oppose
the god of darkness no in that
non-corporeal yellow energy God of Light
was called the Enigma Force it's
basically null's opposite and ensures
the Enigma Force is the symbiotic force
in the Marvel universe that binds
molecules together and holds the
microverse quantum realm in place
remember that part because it's going to
be very important later remember that
the Enigma Force spread its yellow
golden light energy across the universe
to different Warriors of light clad and
golden armor until one day one of the
Enigma forces golden Warriors was
wounded after he and Nell crash landed
on Gore the god butcher's home planet
which then led to gore using null's
necrosword to kill the God of Light for
feeling like the gods of light abandon
him which is of course the origins of
Gore the god butchers butchering but
then after this after War the god
butcher kills this God of Light the
Enigma Force decided to stop handling
its power into multiple beings and then
instead decided to channel a massive
amount of Enigma Force of energy into
its own separate piece of Enigma Force
called the uni power it's basically a
smaller but big chunk of a much larger
Enigma Force and then decided to shove
this
you'd won mortal being at random making
that mortal
many comic book fans know as Captain
Universe a near omnipotent Cosmic level
being with control over matter itself
Peter Parker actually was randomly
chosen by the universe to become a
Captain Universe very briefly which then
spawned his cosmic Spider-Man variant in
the spider-verse and variants we might
very well see in across the spiderverse
very soon and hey guys the beginning of
the year is a great time to sort out all
the stuff that you didn't sort out last
year you know like your life your health
the amount of money that you put aside
for movie merch impulse buys
some of that stuff is hard to do but
some of it is super easy like you could
seriously up your skincare in a hygiene
game by checking out geology geology is
a 16-time award-winning personalized
skin care company recognized in high
Beast birdie Men's Health Esquire and
ask men grooming Awards with over 6 000
5 Star reviews and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you gotta do
is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you geology creates simple
and effective skin care and Hair Care
routines customized just for you with
ingredients that are proven to work no
matter what you're trying to take care
of for hair care you can use geology's
co-wash especially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or harsh ingredients of typical shampoo
geology also has body washes that are
free of harsh ingredients smell great
and are refillable for skin care geology
helps you protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
and vitamin E for serum to keep your
skin looking young and healthy and then
a bit of dermatologist tested aluminum
free deodorants to keep your armpits
smelling not stinky right now for a
limited time geology is hooking up our
viewers with an absolutely insane offer
listen up if you use code rockstar70
they will give you an additional seventy
seven zero percent off their
award-winning skin care trial set we do
the math and that's five products for
just 15 and on top of that you can take
an additional 30 bonus offer on one of
their brand new skin hair and body
products of your choice when you add it
to your trial to get started with
geology just click the link in the
description we thank geology so much for
sponsoring this video you guys are
amazing but anyways like I said before
the Enigma Force is the universal force
that binds atoms together in the Marvel
Universe it's literally what keeps
reality in both the microverses and the
macro verses of light together this
being the case much like Janet Van Dyne
in the MCU in the comics a Quantum realm
Explorer by the name of Arcturus ran has
come into contact with the Enigma Force
and was gifted with immense cosmic power
and telepathy suspiciously similar to
how Janet was able to connect with Scott
in Ant-Man 2 and basically just take
over his body I believe that she was
able to do this because Quantum energy
in the MCU you guys just put the word
Quantum in front of everything is the
Enigma Force or at least a piece of
that's why I believe
I believe able to use the Enigma forces
power that binds the molecules of the
universe together to stabilize ghost
molecules from phasing out of whack
Janet used the Enigma Force to heal
ghost molecular disequilibrium and I
believe this Godly Enigma Force in the
MCU is strongly connected to the yellow
mind Stone in the MCU and could even
potentially be the Divine will of the
Mind Stone itself because you gotta
remember the Mind stone is alive in the
MCU because let's not forget what the
ancient one said in Doctor Strange one
at the root of existence mind and Matter
meet thoughts shape reality and she says
this right after Doctor Strange flies
into a huge yellow energy source and
then flies past a bunch of quantum
energy blasts after he flies inside the
center of that the Enigma Force is
literally the power of light in the
Marvel Universe the power of the Gods
which is why all the gods were gold and
yellow the power of the gods that is
connected to the human mind and the
molecules that make up reality which
could be why xiangchi's Rings glow the
way that they do because they are energy
generators plugging into mind power
within his very Soul allowing him to
concentrate it into this Kamehameha
energy blast at his dad and why the
software used Enigma Force Quantum
energy in their annulax batteries to
evolve the mind of Adam Warlock and make
him their highest evolved The Golden
Warrior and the reason why they're
evolved themselves and why fast dose
uses spinning rings with his weapons
that generate yellow energy blasts and
while the eternals can use the Enigma
Force that connects to your mind to
create a uni mind it's all kinds of
people and Kang wants this God power for
himself which is why Ant-Man has got to
stop him but yeah that is what I believe
this yellow source of energy is in
Ant-Man the lost quadromania it is
quantum energy but it also could very
well be the Enigma Force of the MCU
which lives within the quantum realm in
the comics or microverse but anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at mastertonment
on Twitter if you guys want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] and really insane
theories but more importantly you could
fall into rockstars wherever we are on
the social medias when you do make sure
you hit that notification belt so that
you can get notifications every time we
upload a video and of course do not
forget to hit up new roxasmarch.com so
you can pick up a new shirt for you and
then already loved one in your life
today but again thank you guys so much
for watching this video love you guys so
much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]